cats across the globe and throughout
human history they've been worshiped
revered feared villainized domesticated
and cuddled on the one hand they're
fluffy floofy purring balls of cuteness
but they also act like soul-stealing
demons in japanese folklore they mean
that literally
japan's culture is rich in feline
imagery and folklore most often seen as
protectors defending the home from
everything from mice to bad spirits the
cat is generally revered yet it is also
feared believed to be a possession of
powerful paranormal abilities they bring
curses as quickly as luck
then there's the kasha one of japan's
feline yokai and a literal hellcat this
massive snarling monster arrives in the
midst of raging thunder clouds on a
mysterious floating fireball hell-bent
on stealing your corpse from the arms of
your loved ones and dragging it to the
underworld i mean we all know cats can
be vicious but this seems kind of
extreme did i mention kasha are also
depicted as a flaming chariot that
transports groups of souls to be
tortured in the afterlife
so is it a hell cat or a hell cart
actually it's both
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
japanese yokai are loosely defined as
monsters although any strange or
supernatural creature fits the bill
kasha the cat demons associated with
transporting corpses to their eternal
damnation are certainly yokai and yet
one of the things that makes the kasha
so strange is its very dubious origins
the kanji for kasha translates to fire
cart which is why this giant evil cat
was originally depicted as a literal
flaming cart the hell cart arose in the
kamakura period in japan a time of great
change that included the development of
several new schools of buddhism many
members of the faith saw the period as
the end of times they began producing
hell scrolls paintings often accompanied
by text graphically depicting the souls
of sinners being tortured in various
versions of hell for all eternity the
illustrations were meant to discuss and
horrify people enough that they would
act with kindness and humility while
they were alive so they portrayed things
like giant fighter-breathing roosters
demons chopping up bodies and people
drowning in a river of fiery lava and
some show demons dragging flaming carts
full of damn souls from earth to hell
the hell cart beginning in the edo
period we continue to see images of the
flaming cart but now without the demon
and it's coming down from the sky during
storm
legend had it that if you heard thunder
during a funeral the kasha hellcar was
coming
over time the storm imagery became
entwined with the kasha so much so that
by the late 17th century one book
included a tale about the flaming cart
alongside an illustration of the shinto
deity of thunder and lightning raijin
riding inside it
so that's how the storm imagery joined
our understanding of the creature but
how we got from a flaming storm cart to
a cat is more ambiguous i mean raijin is
certainly frightening in the image but
not really feline in appearance as the
lore and art continued to evolve the
updated forms depicted kasha as hairy
cat-like creatures with long wing-like
ears smooth stomachs and large claws it
was said that during a funeral
procession the kasha would suddenly
appear leap upon the coffin tear open
the lid and drag the corpse with it to
hell
kasha are said to have the power to
control the body of a corpse and even to
wake the dead one cautious story first
published in 1837 shows how the
seemingly disparate supernatural
elements of the kasha could be collected
into one spooky story according to the
legend there lies a great temple in the
achico province full of old documents
and wondrous treasures one of the most
prized possessions in its collection is
a hell wagon repelling linen robe dyed
with the sap of the clove tree and
splattered with blood stains it is said
to have belonged to a virtuous abbot
once a simple linen robe it became a
holy relic after the abbot wore it as he
accompanied a funeral procession through
a great snowstorm they were halfway to
the burial site when black clouds rolled
in making it as dark as night a colossal
fireball appeared out of nowhere and
floated over to the coffin inside the
fireball was a massive horrifying
hellcat with two tails spinning snarling
and hissing it clawed at the coffin
trying to get to the body inside
all of the mourners fled except the
abbot who continued his sacred mantras
as he lifted his holy staff high into
the air he struck the kasha in the head
with all his might splitting the skull
open spraying blood everywhere and
splattering his vestment in hellcat gore
the monster vanished but
wait where had the whole cat thing come
from in the first place i found that
question hard to answer in my research
so i reached out for some help from
heroku yoda author of yokai books
including yokai attack the japanese
monster survival guide yokai a product
of japan's polytheistic world view
youkai are personifications of natural
phenomena unexplainable things
or
concepts the way people see them has
changed a lot over the course of time
long long ago
when bad things happened
like getting sick or some kind of
misfortune people explained it as being
caused by some kind of yokai therefore
people did things to avoid
yokai but today japan is a modern
society so we treat them as fun
characters from folklore if you ask me
about kasia
the main part of the story
is the fire card from hell
with the cat essence attached to that as
a variation i don't know exactly how
or
why they became attached
but there is an old slang term from long
ago
akaneko it means
red cat
it's a slang for fire
because a cat's tongue is red and it
looks like flickering flame
fire was a common danger in daily life
so cats are common and fires are common
and that they could be how kasha became
a fire cat
there is one event we can point to that
had a massive impact on how the kasha
was understood in japanese culture the
publication of toriyama seikin's iconic
1776 yokai encyclopedia
he created the first
encyclopedia of yokai it's called gazu
which
i translated as japandemonium
illustrated
before that yokai had only appeared on
scrolls
with no background
he made a book and he gave each yokai
background in context
it's the most important yokai book this
was the first time the yokai were
presented in standalone narratives
effectively setting the stage for them
to increase their popularity and
solidify their individual characters
zakiyan illustrated the kasha as a cat
demon
sekien doesn't give much story about
kasha
but his illustration is very detailed it
shows a cat-like creature
wreath in fire
carrying a human body
what is important to know
is that fist is only seeking
interpretation
there are many variations in folklore
but broadly speaking
the basic story is this
kasha is a yokai that steals dead bodies
from funerals or graveyards
in some stories
it's the body of a sinner
other times an innocent victim
it varies from place to place even in
all the beautiful weirdness of youkai
kasha are hard to categorize they aren't
quite baki neko a monster cat or goblin
cat since the cat features are secondary
to what actually defines this creature
how it carries away corpses we can call
them yokai since they are monsters but
they really are more like demons given
their hellaciousness and the religious
implications of their actions cats are
ambiguous by nature they can be quiet
and cuddly one moment stealthy and
deadly the next they also toe the line
between feral and domestic
making them easy to perceive as
borderland creatures in other ways as
well in japanese folklore cats are
respected and often feared so the feline
characteristics of the kasha could also
be explained by the long history of cat
superstitions in japan they aren't
necessarily baked niko but there are
many superstitions about cats in japan
in japan there's a superstition
that if a cat leaps over a dead body
that the body will come back to life
there are so many sayings related to
cats in japanese
they are common pets
you can tie a dog up but you can't tie
up a cat
dogs are pack animals who follow owners
orders to behave but cats don't
they have independent spirits so when
you think about that
you can imagine where the superstitions
come from
folklore tradition claims cats can alter
their appearance and bewitch humans so
as the lore of feline yokai like the
kasha developed people began to be more
wary of household cats some claimed cats
would turn into kasha while in the
presence of a dead body so domestic cats
were left outside if a death occurred
others said if cats lived a very long
lifetime it would eventually transform
into the yokai heroku told me that in
japan the kasha is largely unknown
outside of folklore specialists in part
because most funerals today are
cremations the kasha can't steal a body
that isn't there but that doesn't mean
they are destined to fade completely
into the shadows i grew up with yokai
and i loved yokai
ever since i was a child
they are scary
but not too scary
that makes them fun now that i've grown
up i realized that yokai's ability to
characterize things is a powerful tool
for people in hard times
ambiguous
and unknown situations make us nervous
naming them and describing them brings
them under our control
yokai are the faces that help us process
laugh
and move on like today for example we
struggle with covet 19.
we have vaccines
and it feel like we are kind of starting
to control it but in the early month
when it was out of control
there was so much fear
all over the world japanese rediscovered
an old drawing of a yokai from newspaper
240 years ago that showed a yokai called
amabie it said
there will be abundant harvest
but if a plague comes
drow me and show people
people began sharing the drawings on the
social media
and it went viral
not only in japan
but all over the world
even the japanese government started
using amabie on posters and now there
are so many variations
some say it's a she
some say she is an angel who cure plague
there are so many interpretations but it
made people smile and helped people deal
with their fear this is the power
of yokai probably that's how it is with
kasha too
even if they are mainly a form of
entertainment today yokai have only
increased in popularity over time and
the kasha is no exception the monstrous
cat appears in the long-running kataro
cartoon anime and is given this new look
in a recent yokai inspired video game
which if i could side-eye any harder i
would
but in many ways that's the beauty of
monsters one person's hellcart is
another person's hellcat and i think
that makes them even more amazing before
you go if you're looking for a fun show
for the budding young scientists in your
lives we think you would love mega wow
on the pbs kids youtube channel hosted
by comedian katie nguyen the show is
built to get kids excited about science
through fun and wacky experiments we
guarantee your curious scientists will
scream
tell them monstrum sent you
[Music]